-My first guest
is a two-time Oscar winner
and renowned activist.
Her virtual climate movement
"Fire Drill Fridays"
streams live every Friday.
Here is the one and only
Jane Fonda!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my goodness.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
-Oh, please. Whenever.
We're so lucky to have you.
I -- You've -- I just said you
dedicated your life to activism.
And I just want to see
what went through your head
when you heard
the verdict just now?
-I was so relieved,
so grateful to the jury,
so grateful to those policemen
who testified against
one of their own,
testified against Chauvin.
That's so important. But...
Right now, the anvil of justice
is hot.
And we have to seize it
and make sure that we use it
to bend the arc of history
in the direction
that Martin Luther King said --
in the direction of justice.
But the most important thing
as -- For me, as a white person,
we white people have to realize
this isn't a zero-sum game.
You know? They get something,
we lose something -- No.
When Black people can access
healthcare and housing
and decent education
and living wages and so forth,
it doesn't take away from us,
from white people, you know?
It's --
What we don't realize
is that all of us lose.
We all suffer because of racism.
Never was this more obvious
than during the pandemic,
you know, when so many --
Most of the front-line workers
were people of color.
And they were denied the
personal protective equipment.
They were not able to stay home
if they got sick
'cause they couldn't afford to.
We're all in this life together,
and we have to overcome racism.
-Yeah. I agree.
[ Applause ]
You've been in so many protests,
and after seeing the protests
for Black Lives Matter,
what was different about this,
and what stuck out?
-I think for a lot of reasons,
most of them having to do with
the incident itself, you know.
It's very hard to stay
in one place for nine minutes.
That guy was committed
to killing George Floyd.
And we all saw it.
And so the outpourings
that happened
all over the country,
all over the world,
and they lasted, were more
diverse than ever before.
I mean there were communities
here in California
that are all white
that were marching
with Black Lives Matter signs.
I think that during
the pandemic,
a lot of us realized --
Many, many of us realized
for the first time
how so many people,
especially people of color,
are barely hanging on.
And our hearts began to open.
We began to feel empathy.
We need more of that.
They were very unusual,
those protests.
And I think that they've
brought us to where we are now.
And now we have to keep going.
-I read an interesting
quote today.
Someone said that this case
has made activists
out of average citizens.
Do you agree with that?
-I hope that's true.
I hope that's true.
People certainly did turn out,
across race, across age, across
ability, people in wheelchairs,
men and women, across gender.
It was really, really important,
and I hope
that it will continue.
'Cause we have a long way to go.
-Yeah.
Do you remember the exact moment
when you decided you wanted
to become an activist?
-Yeah. It was 1968,
and I was living in Paris,
'cause I was married
to a Frenchman.
And American G.I.s
who had fought in Vietnam
started to teach me
about the war.
And they gave me a book to read
by Jonathan Schell
called "The Village
of Ben Suc."
I read it in one sitting,
and by the time I was through,
I was a different person.
-Is this true?
I read that in around 1970,
before you won your first Oscar,
that you were -- almost decided
to just stop acting
and just devote your life
completely to activism?
-Yeah, I --
You know, I had become a kind of
an organizer, an activist,
and my celebrity separated me
from the people that I was
working with,
and...
I just --
I didn't want to do it anymore.
And this guy,
he became the mayor of Detroit
at one point, Ken Cockrel.
He's a Black lawyer in Detroit,
who was my mentor and my friend,
and he said, "Fonda,
listen to me.
The movement has
plenty of organizers.
We don't have movie stars.
You not only have to
stay with your profession,
but you have to be
more intentional
about how you do it."
And that's when I started
to produce my own movies.
-There you go. That's what
I'm talking about right there.
Absolutely.
-Thank you, Ken Cockrel.
-And here we are. We're talking
about "Fire Drill Fridays."
It's streaming every Friday.
Can you explain to the audience
what this is
and how you came upon this?
-Well, I was motivated
in the fall of 2019
by the student climate
protesters globally,
the biggest protests in history.
And I knew
I wasn't doing enough.
And I'm famous.
I have a platform.
I've got a hit series,
"Grace and Frankie."
Sure helps being an activist
when you have a hit series.
-Yeah, absolutely.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And so I decided
to move to Washington, D.C.
It became a project
of Greenpeace.
And our goal was to reach
the 25 million Americans
who are alarmed
about the climate crisis
but haven't done anything about
it 'cause nobody's asked them.
You know? And there are
apparently 13 million of them
who would engage
in civil disobedience
and risk getting arrested,
but nobody asked them.
So our target
was the great un-asked.
And I figured, you know,
I turned 82 at the time,
and I thought, "Well,
they'll see this old lady
who, you know, she's getting
arrested and going to jail.
Maybe they'll think, 'Well,
I'm really concerned about this.
Maybe I'll do that, too.'"
And people started coming
from all over the country,
mostly women,
mostly older women.
-Wow.
-Washington, Oregon, everywhere.
[ Cheers and applause ]
From all over.
And so when the pandemic hit,
we took it online.
And, you know, in 2020,
we had 9-million-some views
across all platforms.
People have really stuck
with it. It's wonderful.
-And how did you come up with
the name "Fire Drill Fridays"?
-Well, about five days
before the very first one
in October of 2019,
we still had no name.
And we'd been thinking and
thinking
and trying to come up with one.
And a documentary was being
made, and the sound man --
We were packing up to leave,
because we just couldn't
think of a name,
and he took his earphones off,
and he said, "Well, why not
call it 'Fire Drill Fridays'?"
And that was the name.
It was the sound man
on the documentary crew.
-See, and it works,
and it sticks in your head,
and you remember it,
"Fire Drill Fridays."
-Greta Thunberg said,
"We have to act like
our house is on fire,"
like it's a real crisis,
'cause it is.
So we're the fire drill.
We're going to put out the fire.
-For someone just dipping their
toe in the pool or in the water,
what would be the first thing
you'd say, "Well, this is how
you can get involved
to help climate change"?
-Well, the big focus right now
is, um --
Us American taxpayers give money
to the fossil fuel industry.
You know, that's kind of like
dating a guy who beats you up,
but you keep going out with him
and giving him what he wants.
You know?
I mean, just think about this.
Almost 3 million people
have died from COVID
over the last 15 months.
Over the same time frame,
three times as many people,
8.7 million people, have died
because of fossil-fuel-related
air pollution.
And we give $20 billion a year
to these guys?
They are bad guys.
So one of the first things
we have to do is stop --
They're called subsidies --
Stop giving subsidies
to the fossil fuel industry.
So you can go to
firedrillfriday.com,
and it will lead you to where
you can find out how to do it,
how to take action.
Call your elected officials
and President Biden
and demand that not a penny more
should go to these bad guys
that are killing us
and destroying our future.
-Jane Fonda, I thank you so much
for not stopping
and for doing this
for over 50 years.
You're amazing.